we're talking about Wilmer Valderrama
remember we all fell in love with him on
that 70 show and now wouldn't you know
it he's gone all tough guy on NCI yes
you said getting on this show was like
parachuting onto a moving train
I felt like Daniel Craig you know I
landed and I I didn't fall off the [ __ ]
and it's like okay now keep going
ha ha sure Wilmer can be all
double-oh-seven with his action scene
run seems high but does he have what it
takes to fill Michael Weatherly shoes
you bet he does he's definitely a ladies
man and he also brings a little comic
relief all right what did I miss
jacket as for agent Gibbs are you coming
Torres doesn't seem intimidating I'm not
much of a varsity letters guy Wilmer
plays an NCIS field agent emerging from
a mysterious Deep Cover assignment
do you even know a lot about him yet
have you were making it up as you go
hello from the state of NCIS I'm here
with my amazing cast hi hey
behind the scenes Wilmer brings the fun
to this cast and gotta say the fact that
he looks like this shirtless makes us
happy to say welcome aboard
agent Torres so you said everybody's
been really nice but what if I told you
that there may be a prank plot against
you that is food I would feel really bad
for them I think I know this is going it
has to be Emily maybe I'll do something
a Wilmers
trailer she thinks she's very slick but
I see it coming no but for real though
what he's in China do you a deep-cover
agent you find out we'll find out oh
Emily Emily I'm sorry I swear uncover
goods I swear I didn't give up the good
I'd be a terrible suspect right Kevin
you can't hold a secret I can't hold
water but that is one of the best sets
in the business I'm playing have fun